[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
implementing shallow screening
strategies to accelerate microbial
strain improvement
i am kayleigh bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by inscripta
to learn more visit inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
eileen spindler senior director of
applications at inscripta eileen you may
now begin your presentation
good morning
thank you for joining our webinar today
my name is eileen spindler and i'm the
senior director of applications at
inscripta
today i'm going to talk to you about how
we implement shallow screening
strategies
to accelerate microbial strain
improvement
you guys are all here today because you
understand what the opportunities there
are with microbial cell processes and
rapid strain engineering both from the
host genome engineering types time point
as well as targeting and engineering
we know that microbes can allow us to
produce natural products
proteins
and can be able to allow us to scale
sustainable products into the future
however with all these different
opportunities there's a lot of
challenges in being able to maximize
performance and to be able to have the
right tools to make better strains
better genetic elements
and better methods for rapid testing
these challenges aren't new and they're
something that a lot of the scientists
in the field have been talking about for
quite a while
synthetic biology as a term has been
around for about 15 years
biologists have typically tried this
approach as engineers but have this has
often been met with limited success
and that's because there's about five
hard truths of synthetic biology and
this came from a paper in in nature in
2010
and this is because there's a lot of
things that are hard to predict about
the system because many of the parts are
undefined the circuitry of the biology
is unpredictable
the system is complex
and changes to the system can be
detrimental
these challenges make it difficult to
predict
deadly model your system like designing
a circuit board or designing a building
so that you can tackle your design
rationally
however in the meantime without that
knowledge and that engineering mindset
we have to rely on a forward engineering
type approach
where we can empirically cycle design
generate test and learn
to optimize our system
here at onyx and using the onyx platform
we've created this with the mindset of
streamlining and optimizing the steps
around the dgtl cycle
so that customers can crank through
quickly and efficiently and optimize
their system
so what do we model our work off of
we model our work off of the thought
around evolution and how evolution and
diversity generation through evolution
is a powerful forward engineering
process
we know by thinking about natural
selection
artificial selection by breeding as well
as directed evolution
we've been able to move forward and use
biology and use evolution to inspire the
next generation of tools and chemicals
that can be used
to help us in
nature how these approaches work is
really from letting nature tell us what
works and what doesn't
and this process works very slowly now
without the direction and
moves more quickly when
directed so how do we move through this
biological sequence space in a directed
fashion
while being able to really thoroughly
optimize for that diversity
so let's get started by first talking
about what we're talking what we see
here right so as a reminder
we're working with the very extremely
vast and complex space of the genome
and if you look at it from a protein
pathway and genome level the number of
variants that you could use to optimize
a specific pathway for example here
we're looking at a pathway that would
allow you to produce icing
the sequence space is so vast it's not
something that you'd be able to use a
brute force approach to optimize
so here we start to get down into the
details about how we use forward
engineering to start to unlock the power
of biology
ford engineering unlocks the power of
biology because when we look in the
genotype to phenotype space
you can think about working through
fitness in a complex unknown space
similar to traversing a geographical
space as depicted in the image here
in this image what you see is a
landscape that maps fitness or
improvement of your particular strain of
interest
over sequence space
and what you can think about is what are
the tools and strategies that allow you
to get from point a to point b or point
one to point two
and then least amount of steps quickly
and efficiently
but we can also tell by looking at the
sequence space is there a lot of ways to
get to that improved fitness space
and so what you want to do is you want
to think about how to generate diversity
across this sequence space
and how to combine those pieces of
diversity to quickly take you up this
this mountain as we call it
so there's two concepts that are derived
from poutine engineering that allow us
to attack both diversity and com and
optimization
the first is diversity generation right
so in diversity generation given a
sequence space how do you interrogate it
to identify meaningful or beneficial
edits
here you're creating many mutations
hoping to discover some that are
beneficial
secondly in combinatorial optimization
how do you then take those identified
edits
and efficiently recombine them to move
up the fitness space
so add in scripta
we've taken both of these two concepts
and this is what i'll talk through today
the first concept is how we generate
that diversity
we've generated all of our diversity and
in the examples that i'm going to show
you today are showing you how we
generated dice diversity using the onyx
platform
is the world's first bench up platform
for scalable digital genome engineering
with push button simplicity
it allows us to make single edits across
the genome in e coli and yeast
along with this diversity generation
we've applied this workflow that allows
us to do combinatorial optimization
this is an iterative genome engineering
workflow
in round one we generate our edits
through the onyx platform we then get a
pool of cells that are diversity
generated cells we isolate this we make
our top hits and then we move forward
selecting from these tits
to go into the second round of diversity
generation
we continue to move through this process
quickly identifying hits that have a
certain fold improvement over the
baseline performance and move quickly
through iterative genome engineering
workflows using onyx in every step of
the way to be able to get to our target
improved phenotype more quickly
so these are the two pieces that we've
used to be able to ask key questions in
ford engineering to improve
in specific application spaces
so now i'm going to move into the part
of the webinar where we talk about how
we use this approach to answer key
questions in forward engineering and how
to set up our workflow so that we can
use shallow screening to move through
sequence space more quickly
so the strategies that we sort of we
think about in ford engineering is how
do i move through design generate test
and learn more quickly
and what's important to do is to set up
some high level strategy and questions
that you want to ask before getting
started
we first want to know
what our goals are
what are the strategies that will best
help achieve these goals
how do we balance design generate test
and learn
we'll walk through some of the examples
of this about how we balance these
different approaches
then once we generate these different
hits
this feeds directly into planning your
phenotyping workflows so how do you plan
how many isolates you would wish to test
we'll then finish up with strategies to
move quickly through the dgtl cycles and
i'll give two very specific examples
both e coli and east how we've applied
these approaches to be able to generate
diversity and do iterative
engineering to show improved performance
of our different strains
so one
the first question that we ask as we set
up this workflow is what are my goals
for diversity generation
and therefore what are the strategies
that i want to consider to get to the
desired endpoint
so i know i want to create diversity in
particular strains i want to create
different edits
and i want to know what type of
approaches i should use how many edits
should i make what kind of edits should
i make
so
the first question is what is overall
goal
of diversity generation
and here at inscripta the goal that we
look for in in high level is
to obtain plenty of diversity to fuel
that combinatorial optimization
you can have targeted strategies
as well as discovery strategies
and in these different approaches you
may either have prior ideas of where to
intervene in a gene or a pathway and you
may want to dive dive into these to
learn or optimize based on your
knowledge
we also know there's a lot of dark
matter in biology there's unknown space
to work in
and you may want to try to scan over a
larger set of targets
but as you can see in these different
examples in strategy one this is a
targeted strategy where you have a prior
idea of where you want to intervene in a
gene or a pathway
and you can have a 10 success rate
because you have a better idea of what
you're looking to target
you may screen less and you'll still see
10 hits when you have a 10 success rate
with a hundred variants screened
on the uh flip side when you use a
discovery strategy you may have a much
lower success rate you'll screen a lot
more
but when you screen a lot more you may
see more hits and more hits that are
within the sequence base that were
unexpected
the product of both of these two
approaches gives you a larger amount of
diversity to fuel that next step which
is combinatorial optimization
so in other words the value for forward
engineering is in having as many edits
and recombining them quickly
rather than in knowing where to look
focusing in on what you think is best
may truly prevent you from achieving the
best result
so using this i want to give an example
of a protein engineering approach that
use this
to be able to understand how to move
through forward engineering just
specifically on an enzyme scale
this is an example that came from a
paper back in 2014
and in this paper they didn't use onyx
but they looked to do diversity
generation and optim combinatorial
optimization to improve a single enzyme
carbonic anhydrase
so this example from protein engineering
highlights these concepts
the mutations here are amino acid
substitutions
but when you think about this you can
apply this to any edit type
here the researchers were interested in
engineering higher thermostability of a
carbo carbonic anhydrase enzyme and
started by doing diversity generation
using saturation mutagenesis across the
protein
this led to the creation of the library
with the thousands of different edits
when you go to screen this type of
library you do not need to see
everything to make progress
here
we they saw a hundred fold improvement
when sampling fifty 50 of the library
as i started to move through this
sequence base and started to do
optimization on this protein
you can see that they looked at about
half of the possible substitutions
in the first step pulled out a stockpile
of single amino acid substitutions that
were beneficial
and then they recombined these to
generate larger libraries but only
followed through with shallow sampling
of the library itself as they move
through the sequence space so as you can
see here
they saw
increased fold improvement over these
six different rounds of combinatorial
optimization
in which they had varying levels of
samples that they screened
so you can think about cycling through
these rounds by diversity generation and
combinatorial optimization
to quickly get to an optimal phenotypic
performance and this is the type of
strategy that we want to apply when we
use the onyx platform
so in this example again it was only
looking at single amino acid
substitutions
this is where the sequence space and the
things that have come to fruition in
synthetic biology have improved in the
last while
and so the next question we ask is what
strategies should i consider to achieve
my goals
with this what i'm asking is what type
of diversity do i want to generate
so here we're searching for good moves
in a vast sequence space
what kind of edits do you want to make
right diversity can come from anywhere
diversity can come from all edit types
any edit type can be a hit an insertion
a substitution a deletion
these are
knockouts they're promoters they're
terminators they're rbs's
there any sequence that you can dream up
these edit types and hits can be located
all over the genome
and these hits can be found again as i
described before either using a targeted
approach or a discovery approach
so you can bring these types of thoughts
to unlock unlock your imagination
when we think about what we want to do
in improving a particular strain of
interest
for
protein or pathway or on the genome
level we know there's a lot of different
areas that we can focus on
this slide just helps us think about all
the different levers and dials you can
work with specifically these are things
that we use
using the onyx technology for today
you can modify protein function directly
with tools such as truncations saturated
mutagenesis or domain or site swaps
you can also modify transcriptional
regulation with edits such as promoter
or terminator swaps transcription factor
binding sites for example
and you can also go after translational
regulation through codon optimization
and translational initiation sites
so here i'm giving you all ideas about
how you create that diversity and what
you want to design to
and so the next question is of course
well if i can design all this how do i
balance how do i make sure that i screen
what i need to screen to be able to move
through this fast sequence space
so here's how we tackle the next step
how do i balance design generate and
test
it's very important to balance these
capacities so when we're speaking about
balancing capacities within the dgtl
cycle what we're talking about is
throughput mismatches between the
various steps of the cycle
classical genomic engineering really
fails to take advantage of modern
testing capabilities
generate if done by and
limits the process to a small number of
edits across the genome
automation moves that forward but
doesn't fully realize the potential of
the downstream the inscriptive platform
allows you to generate number of edits
to fuel your pipeline and significantly
improve your boost to both design
and generate with regards to both volume
and efficiency
so the next thing you have to think
about is once you've designed and
generated these
using robotic automation and now today
using inscripta we want to be able to
correctly balance
this generate and
test and so i want to use some examples
using a graphics to be able to show how
you want to move forward quickly but
also how to correctly balance this and
how you sort of think about that
from
from a testing standpoint
i'm going to make this very simple and
say
the goal in forward engineering is
usually to maximize the number of unique
observations of particular unique edits
and so as i look at this graph here
we're looking at two different things
on on the x-axis it's the number of
isolates you would screen
and on the y is the number of unique
edits observed
and each one of these is the number of
edits that you used in this library that
you were screening
the green is when you have a thousand
uh different designs the yellow is when
you have five thousand and the blue is
when you have 10 000.
and when you're looking at this is that
in ford engineering
what we're saying is under sampling a
large library is actually a good
strategy this is similar to the story i
told before about
carbonic anhydrase
with large libraries
the early to middle part of the curve
is the most efficient space for you to
spend your phenotyping resources
what this is showing you is that you'll
have more unique edits per screening
and higher return of investment for your
work
conversely
if you use a smaller library
but you put in relatively higher amount
of phenotyping resources you will see a
smaller fraction of unique hits
and this makes sense if you know which
edits will be useful
so this is if you have a very targeted
library and you want to see more
but if you truly want to look at
diversity
the best way to approach this is to
build larger libraries and to screen
them at a 1x to 2x screening capacity
and this is a good strategy to start
with
and this is just a mock example and i'll
next show how we did this in different
libraries at the end of this talk
another thing that is is something that
we need to consider is how library
composition affects phenotyping
performance
phenotyping performance is affected by
the percent of cells that contain your
edit
as well as the designs that are
represented
and these two numbers can now be used to
help develop your phenotyping plan
when you plot out your design
representation bucketing the counts of
isolates per design
you will typically see a spread where
some designs are relatively
over or under represented
the curve on the right represents the
random sampling of the design
distribution either via screening or
selection
what this curve shows is that if you go
and screen the number of isosceles shown
on the x-axis
what you have on the y-axis is the
number of unique edits that you observe
what you're seeing here is if the edit
rate is either 100
or 35 percent
then you're able to show the difference
in the screening capacity that's needed
if your edit rate or the fraction of
edits that you need in the population
are observed
so these are both important things and
tools that have been developed had in
scripta
that help you apply the right
phenotyping resources
and decide where you want to be
so this is where we go into moving to
how do i plan my test workflows now that
i understand how
for the edited cells and the design
representation
affects the type of phenotyping
performance i will observe
so let's plan our phenotyping workflow
there's a lot of different examples of
screening but here's a very specific one
that's one that we use adam scripta
this is a plate-based direct test by
mass spec
here we're taking an engineered
cell library
we isolate those we do a colony picking
then goes into liquid handling
incubation and detect detection of a
particular analyte of interest
we then do phenotyping analysis and then
genotyping
and when going through this approach the
questions we have to ask are how many
should i screen
what do i need to do to move forward the
most quickly and to to be able to pair
both the design build and test cycles
here
in order to make optimal use of your
library and screening resources you need
to think about how many isolates you
want to screen
the goal with these screens is to be
efficient with your resources
be as efficient as possible with your
resources but you know that there are
certain limitations that you may have
you may have limitations in your
screening capacity the number of designs
that you have in your library the edit
rate and design distribution that you
may see
so some loose solutions that we expect
to see here is that you want to make
larger libraries and you don't want to
over sample these libraries again the
focus is on unique edits observed
versus your phenotyping capacity that
you have
you don't want to over sample this
library what we usually say is about 10
to 50 coverage results in finding
beneficial diversity without wasting
screening resources
and focus again
moving fast through the design generate
test and learn cycle
now to reiterate this graphically
your efficiency sweet spot will be in
that mid-range with a large library
this is where you're going to continue
to see unique edits observed
across what your phenotyping capacity
may be
shallow sampling large edit libraries
will provide rapid gains in terms of
this unique edit size that you would see
similar to selection characterizing your
library through sequencing will provide
you with the metrics needed to plan the
scope and the number of isolates that
you would wish to screen
we will talk about this in more detail
in some of our examples about how we're
matching our phenotyping approaches
with the number of unique edits we'd
wish to observe
so the next question is how do i move
fast through these cycles right so i now
know how to generate like diversity and
i know how to screen but i want to move
fast i want to be able to understand
um how to improve my protein of interest
the most quickly
and so
there's a very simple way of sort of
thinking about this and that is
speed often wins over perfection so here
is kind of a funny concept to sort of
think about and what this is trying to
leave you with is that
investment analogy where the time
constant as the exponent is much more
important than the base when it comes to
compounded fold improvement
so in this graph shows
in green which is this lower here
trying to find the best edit per round
so here i'm looking for a three-fold
improvement per round in this case
when you take more time per round
it requires more time right so you can
only move so far per month
however if you compare that to the
strategy of moving faster with less
improvement per round here is showing a
two-fold improvement
that strategy in blue
wins out rapidly over time
and here is just a simple time scale of
a year
where we're moving to look for a
two-fold versus three-fold improvement
through each one of these cycles
we have found that this is also to be
true in biological systems
which makes us look to try to improve
towards combinatorial diversity faster
so
very simply stated
we want to move quickly to the next
round
so how do we do this we find hits and
move
screening and screening approaches we
re-test and genotype the top hits that
we see in parallel
identify that parent for the next round
and move forward
it's often not necessary to identify a
perfect parent and diversity at each
round so again speed wins over
perfection
boltar says the best is the enemy of the
good
so our next thing to think about is
how do we show examples of this at
inscripta and how have we applied this
thought process and how we work through
this uh internally
the first example i'm going to give you
is a screeners workflow here we're
showing you an example of how we're
improving small molecule production in e
coli
so an earlier slide i showed you an
example of how we have protein pathway
and genome to improve metabolic
engineering
here we're showing you that example
again very specifically for e coli for
lysine biosynthesis
in our approach here we knew we wanted
to make designs that were
protein pathway as well as on the genome
to improve lysine biosynthesis
we wanted to do a very large approach
where we focused on knockout libraries
pathway libraries as well as promoter
libraries
in this example
in discovery example here
we had 24 libraries that we sampled with
over 200 000 total designs
we then did a plate-based assay where we
did our agilent rapid fire ms to look
for lysine in which we screened eighteen
thousand isolates of these two hundred
thousand total designs
as you can see using knockout pathway
and very targeted promoter libraries we
saw differential approved improvements
in each one of these libraries
these numerous hits in the primary
screening was across multiple library
types both targeted as well as discovery
approaches
what we found here in this discovery
approach specifically when just looking
at this lysine biosynthesis pathway
piece
is in pathway and
engineering
we targeted these 19 lysine biosynthesis
pathway genes
within this we looked at 20
transcriptional factors
both global and site saturation
eugenesis
and what we found by focusing on this
pathway here
we saw 138 unique hits
of which there was a fold improvement of
these hits between two-fold to a
thousand-fold over wild-type
so what this really shows you is that
there's a very fast return on investment
to do rapid interrogation of these
targets
the next thing we need to do is to
rapidly down select these targets
and to be able to move fast through this
to combine these improvements to to
increase lysine production
so here's just an example of round one
in round one we're looking at two
different hits that we saw
these different hits are the dap a
enzyme
this adapt a enzyme has two hits one is
in the promoter region
in front of dapa
the other is within the enzyme itself
the next thing we did is just in
combining these two hits
combining these two hits showed over a
ten thousand fold improvement
and then lastly
is looking at the third round
this third round
was a combination of three different
hits
two hits within the dappy jean and
another on off this pathway itself
showing a 14 000 fold improvement
over the wild type
within this scheme
what i want to show you here and to
focus on very clearly is that our first
round when we did our diversity
generation
took us two months to get to these hits
when we started to stack combinatorial
diversity this round two took us three
weeks
and round three
was five weeks
so within three rounds of editing we
were seeing a 14-fold improvement and we
saw this all was happened in 14 months
of turnaround time
so this is really the power of what
we're showing you with regards to doing
both a shallow screening approach and to
move quickly through both diversity
generation and combinatorial
optimization
here we're using multiple design
strategies at the protein pathway and
genome level
and we're doing rapid performance
improvements through three rounds of
editing
all right so our next story
here we're focused on
improving protein production
we're improving protein production here
using the onyx workflow
in yeast
so first i'm going to set up the story
about how we're improving protein
production specifically
of cbh1 a heterologous enzyme
in this workflow we started with a base
strain build we used yeast strain of sun
pk and we did a single copy genomic
integration of the heterologous gene of
cellular biohydrolase 1
cvh1
this is an important enzyme in
industrial applications for the
degradation of cellulose
here we did a chromosomal expression of
this particular
enzyme to eliminate any copy number
variation that we may see
and also allow for unbiased assessment
of activity improvement throughout the
process
on the back end of this strain build we
also built an activity assay that was a
very um
not a very high throughput screening
workflow in this screening workflow we
were looking at a fluorescent output
for cbh1 activity using 96 weld plates
in which we could use do about 10 plates
per day
this was a very high sensitivity assay
but
not as high throughput
as some other approaches
the next thing we wanted to do
is to be able to figure out how to do
our targeted discovery diversity
strategies
so in cbh1 story there was both targeted
and discovery diversity generation
designs that were used on onyx
here those targeted strategies were in
building libraries that focused on the
the promoter in front of cbh1
the signal sequence site saturation
library
the cbh1 kozaki sequence modifications
and a cbh1 site saturation library
we also did discovery strategies these
were genome-wide knockouts genome-wide
terminator insertions
genome-wide promoter deletions
and protease and glycosylation pathway
modifications
the next thing that we want to show you
is after looking at these targeted and
discovery strategies
is how we use the shallow screening
approach of these libra libraries to
identify strains with improved
phenotypes
so as we go through these two different
approaches here we have this targeted
libraries as well as these discovery
libraries
and within this
our library sizes range from about 200
to over 5000
in these seven libraries we designed
over 15 almost about 15 000 designs and
we screened about
eight thousand of those
the library coverage that we saw between
targeted and discovery uh approaches
ranged from about four percent to sixty
eight percent
and we saw about 136 total isolates that
were hits
of these hits 74 were unique
where we saw independent of whether we
used it target or the step coverage
strategy
a two percent hit rate
so again when you think about how
your phenotyping capacity could be
limited and the number that you might be
able to screen
it's better to shallowly screen several
libraries than to screen a few deeply
and so again i want to go back to that
one picture that we showed in our
previous section that shows you how
several factors influence that
phenotyping strategy
here again phenotyping a library
coverage is dependent on several
different factors the number of total
designs that you may see
the edit a fraction the distribution of
edits and the number of samples that you
screened
so as i showed before we had a very
different range between the percent of
the library that we saw and the number
of hits that we saw
at inscripta we use our resolver
platform to be able to understand the
percentage of the library that you would
see and the number or the number of
designs
based on the number of isolates that you
screen
so again here what you are seeing is
that if you're focused just specifically
on a genome-wide knockout library with
about 5000 designs
if you had an edit fraction of 69
and you screen the 1x coverage of that
library
this is the percent of library that you
would see
you would see about 31 percent
and what we did see again right just
with that genome wide library that gina
wide live knockout library here
when we did about 18 coverage of it
we did see 26 unique hits from that
library using the shallow screening
approach
in which our hit rate in this library
was two percent
now i'm going to go into little details
about both the targeted libraries that
we saw as well as discovery libraries to
show you kind of the power of both the
inscriptive technology and shallow
screening to be able to understand these
approaches
here we're showing you the targeted
library that interrogated the promoter
architecture
here we showed we retargeted this
library to transcription factor binding
sites where we made insertions
substitutions and deletions
as you can see within this promoter
that's upstream the cbh1 gene
we had a variety of different hits that
localized towards the center of this of
this particular
promoter region
this is just one example about how
targeted libraries are allowing us to
really understand and interrogate this
promoter architecture and what was
important for improving cvh1 expression
and activity
secondly we looked at the discovery
libraries again to try to understand
what
cellular processes
impacted and improved protein expression
in this shallow straining approach we
saw a number of genes that were targeted
in fact 69 different genes were targeted
that varied from things that we knew a
lot about would possibly improve our
protein
production
to others that were unknown or
completely other pathways that were
unexpected
so this is the diversity that we
generated to move into the next step
that next step is shown here
in our first round hits we took two
separate hits that were part of the
genome-wide knockout library
and then we took a this first round hits
library
so we took a combination of several
different isolates pooled them to move
on to our second round
our first round hits gave us a second
round hit the second round hits library
was then
placed um on our first round hits
library and then we moved to our third
round hits
so again the idea here is to move
quickly through this iterative
combinatorial editing approach to get to
that third round where we start to see
improved returns
here is just a snapshot shot again of
all of these different rounds of editing
and this is our primary screening data
here what you're seeing is in fold
improvement over the base string the
base drain that contain the cbh1 gene
here is our first round of hits
here are seven libraries these are our
seven libraries that are both targeted
as well as part of genome discovery
and you can see a range of fold
improvement over the base stream that
was observed
again we
we then took our genome-wide knockout on
our first round
here are those two different genome wide
knockout libraries that were used on our
first round hit
and then here is the hits on our first
round in round two
lastly
the hits on round two
we're then moved to this third round and
here we can see almost a four-fold
improvement over our base strain that
was observed
we then moved to scale this up to make
sure that we could validate this work
over time and what we see is that this
translate to shake flask
our top hit had a four fold improved
over the base strain
and as you can see as you move through
each of these rounds you saw increased
improvement over time
so i'm going to follow finalize this to
really show you how the onyx platform
was enabling this rapid learning cycle
here for this particular example we did
seven libraries and saw seven 74 unique
hits in three months the second round
took us 1.5 months
third round took us another 1.5 months
and so in six months we had a strain
with fourfold improvement in protein
production of cbh1
of three edits
in only six months
so the design here this is where we're
showing how the onyx platform helps you
move through this process faster it only
took about a half hour to design these
libraries
per library and so a few hours
at that
the build hands-on time was about 20
minutes the onyx instrument does this
for you
and most of our time was then moved
towards phenotyping and genotyping these
libraries
so i'll leave you with some thoughts
right what are you going to do and how
are you going to expand your experiments
when you can create thousands of single
cells with edits that are trackable
you can distribute these edits around
the genome
you can employ any combination of
insertions deletions and substitutions
and you can do it all in the same
experiment
we can look at this and then
ask again
i'm looking to make diversity generation
and do shallow screening
what is your goal how do i go about this
how do i match design generate test and
learn don't waste phenotyping resources
on seeing everything
and under sample large libraries to fuel
your optimization
lastly move forward with a sense of
urgency
don't linger on obtaining perfect
results at each round
thank you so much for taking the time to
listening to me today
looking forward to hearing your
questions and seeing how you would want
to use onyx in the future
thank you eileen for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started
our first question here is a two-part
question and this asks how many fold
grader do i build the library compared
to my screening capacity is there a
point of diminishing returns
yeah thank you very much for this
question um to sort of answer this very
quickly the point of diminishing returns
starts when you are no longer
phenotyping unique isolates right
so what you want to understand is when
you're going to get to that point where
you're no longer going to be seeing
unique things to be able to do this
phenotyping
and so that helps answer the first part
of this question right so in general um
and and what we've talked through the
the entire seminar about is
how to recommend what sampling size that
you would use
and so in general we recommend sampling
your library at about a one to two fold
uh
screening depth larger than your library
size so this kind of means that
if you have a screen
say that allows you to sample ten
thousand isolates per day
then a library that's about five
thousand to ten thousand is a good match
for your screen
so this is something that really is is
at inscripto we've developed a lot of
phenotyping assay tools to best pair
these two things
but at the end of the day what's
important is that you get to the you
don't get to the point of those
diminishing returns
i hope that answers your question
great thank you looks like we have
another um sort of follow-up question to
this one how much does biology play a
role in this decision
well biology plays a role i think in in
all of our work right um as as we said
before biology's uh you know kind of a
dark space here that we're still trying
to learn how to engineer
uh where this may make um
uh uh
make you have to sort of think about it
would be
if you were targeting something like
essential genes for example so you may
find that many of your edits would not
be observed after you had designed them
likely because that particular edit type
in that essential gene
could impact fitness so this is another
part of the workflow where really trying
to understand what is in your library
for starting your phenotyping will help
you understand what you need to
phenotype and how deeply you'd need to
screen
thank you
next question here is there really value
in knocking out all genes in the genome
when i know a lot of them may not give
me a hit
oh very good question um so in the cbh1
story right we just showed you that we
did both a targeted genome-wide knockout
library
as well as we did a full genome-wide
knockout library
and so this question really comes back
to to you and your particular
applications
uh and what are your goals for with
regards to diversity generation
so when we did both the genome-wide
knockout library and a targeted knockout
library we saw about two percent hit
rate in each of those libraries and some
of the same hits were identified in each
one of those libraries we did however
find things in the genome-wide knockout
library where we weren't targeted that
we didn't expect
so there is value that we saw specific
to that example but again it really goes
back to what's your question and and
where do you want to start with regards
to interrogating the sequence space
all right another question we have here
can i still build diversity by targeting
a gene family instead of a single gene
or the entire genome
oh yes yeah of course so when you think
about diversity generation and design
this is another example that you know
we've talked about between targeted and
discovered it kind of falls in between
those two
there's a lot of diversity between
particular gene families
and a lot of cryptic genes that can be
turned into something that might be
beneficial
so building diversity on the specific
jean family is a great idea and a good
thing to follow through on
right
another question here i see the value in
shallow screening of large libraries are
there any reasons to build small
libraries for screening
yes there is right um so we showed a
couple of different examples on library
size and and really you know kind of the
key thing that we wanted to get across
is that you wanted to get to a point of
diminishing returns right
um with a small library
it would make sense to build this if you
know which edits will be useful
this strategy is worth the effort right
if you expect a higher hit rate of your
different edit types
right and it looks like we have time for
one more question here and this one asks
in the lysine example you showed that
the second round resulted in the
combination of two dap mutants found in
the first round however you showed that
libraries were made and screened not
just one combination what were these
libraries in the second round
so the libraries in the second round
were made up of a subset of hits that we
saw in the first round
so in the first round we made a larger
diversity library right where we look to
capture
a lot of the different things that we
saw in the
genes the pathways as well as across the
genome
in that second library we took those
hits that we saw for the first library
and we used those hits to build on our
first round libraries
does that answer your question i hope
i'm sure it did thank you so much
all right well thank you again eileen
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
labrutz and our sponsor in scripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you